GUEST SPEAKER: Good morning.
As you know, this past July
our National Council overturn
legislation made
in December that
would have allowed Uranium
Resources Incorporated to start
mining near Church Rock.
This is the same
Church Rock that
was the site of the largest
release of radioactive material
in US history, even larger than
the Three Mile Island accident
but with much less
media coverage.
Over 1,000 tons of
radioactive waste
and 93 millions of gallons
of radioactive waste
water were dumped into the
Puerco River that day in 1979.
For those of you that
remember, the warnings
came late and in English only.
So our people went on
with business as usual.
Many of our relatives
suffered for it.
To this day the
government has not
measured the health
effects of the spill.
Now, within 35 years of
the Church Rock spill,
there are members
of our community
that are willing to open up
our lives to mining again.
Thankfully, the council's ruling
has held off URI and others.
But these mining
companies were waiting
with bated breath
for any opportunity
to mine on our lands.
The voices demanding access
to domestic sources of energy
are growing.
We need to prepare our community
for inevitable discussions
about uranium mining.
I'm not here today to
argue whether or not
we should allow mining.
I know a lot of you want the
economic growth and the jobs.
I'm here instead to outline
a strategy for integrating
our voices into state
and federal policy making
and to highlight the
challenges that we face.
So I'll start first
with the challenges.
Integrating our knowledge
into the broader discourse
will be an uphill battle.
First, we face
major disadvantages
compared to the
mining companies.
We don't have an
organized constituency.
We can't compete with them
in terms of resources.
And we don't have the
influence that they
have over politicians.
Second, many will dismiss
us for not being scientific
and will try to argue that we're
motivated by our own interests
and, therefore, not impartial.
Third, the scientific data
isn't clearly on our side yet.
The scientific community
has shown that uranium
has made our community sick.
But there hasn't been
enough money or time
spent on how it's made us sick.
So why is that important for
us to be able to clearly share
our narrative about these health
impacts with the government
and broader public?
And why is it important
that we ourselves
understand the full
extent of these impacts?
Because the government and
corporations have failed us.
Not just failed us, they've
dismissed and rejected us.
So moving forward,
what is our strategy?
First, we will
develop a task force
that will be in charge of
mobilizing community members
and spearheading an
outreach program to let
our community know
about the efforts
to reduce local knowledge
about the health
impacts of the uranium mining.
Second, reach out to
the scientific community
for local partners.
Several institutions such as
the University of New Mexico
and Southwest Research
and Information Center
have expressed interest
in health data.
The task force can work
to get these scientists
from different institutions
to partner with us on this.
Third, facilitate
the conversation
around the type of
data we should collect
with members of the
scientific community
and our own community.
Fourth, train researchers
within our community
to conduct
face-to-face interviews
in English and Navajo.
Make phone calls,
organize public forums
to collect data about
community health.
And the data can
then be validated
through random sampling
to ensure validity.
Fifth, pair
community researchers
with members of the
scientific community
to analyze and
interpret findings
in a language that
can be understood
within the scientific
community but also
within our own community.
And then hold public meetings
around this information
to facilitate discussion about
the health effects of uranium
mining as well as the
impacts of the remaining
remnants of mining.
Finally, the task
force should pair
with members of the
scientific community
to release findings
to local media,
environmental organizations,
and to the broader public.
Our strategy then is to
ensure that our community is
knowledgeable about the
impacts of uranium mining
so that we can understand
the full impact of opening
our lands up again and to
be able to translate what
we have suffered
in our own language
and technical language
necessary to make people sit up
and take notice of us.
So I'll leave you with these
numbers; 29, 521, and 30.
A 2000 study showed that
Navajo uranium miners
are 29 times more
likely than Navajos
that are not involved in
mining to develop lung cancer.
There are now 521 abandoned
mines across the Navajo Nation.
Although the federal
government is taking the lead
to clean up after
these mines, it
will take billions of dollars
and hundreds of years.
It's time that we
just don't have.
And the mining has left scars
on our water and our land
that you can now estimate
that 30% of our people
don't have access to
uncontaminated water.
The EPA has been
a valuable partner
in cleaning up old mines but
there's still much to do--
sorry, but there's still much
to do in protecting ourselves.
So we must convince the
government that they cannot
stand by and watch as waste from
the mining continues to seep
into our water,
land, and our bodies.